well it's my pleasure to do this non
live-streaming performance for you and
I'll be talking to you today about the
application of Informatics bound from
attics and metagenomics to our project
which is to study bacteria and how they
interact with fungi my name is Patrick
Jane I'm from Los Alamos National Lab
and I thought I'd give you a quick tour
through the National Lab System if
you're unfamiliar with it we are part of
the department of energy complex of
National Labs we're one of the larger
national labs with almost ten thousand
or more employees primarily not in
biology which is the topic for today
we're in the middle of New Mexico
northern New Mexico very pleasant if you
haven't heard about us well it's fairly
famous currently although it was a
secured City at at the beginning or
during the bond the effort with the with
the war and another thing that's kept
secret is that there is biology at Los
Alamos and in fact in terms of my area
of study with genomics and
bioinformatics Lionel has a long history
with essentially beginning the human
genome project they're also the the
creation of GenBank also originated at
Los Alamos before it was transferred to
NIH so we study a lot of things using
genomics and bioinformatics as tools to
investigate various systems but today
I'll be focusing on on one project to
look at bacteria and fungi so similar to
to what we know now about ourselves the
human microbiome and other animals it's
becoming an accepted concept that fungi
also
have a series of bacterial partners and
this concept is starting to take root in
the community with a lot more
individuals studying bacteria and the
relationship with fungi I think a lot of
this has come about due to genomics I'm
just showing here
one of the first discoveries I have paid
attention to because it dealt with
berkel Dario which I was studying at the
time and that happens to this particular
species is an end of semi on of this
rice pathogen fungus rice opposed and it
turns out that it's the bacterium that
actually creates the toxin for the
fungus and so it's really the bacterium
that's harmful for rice it also managed
to hijack control of reproduction in the
fungus which is also of great interest
and since then there have been a large
number of studies looking at all aspects
of bacteria and how they interact with
their fungal hosts we wanted to take
advantage of this brand new and emerging
field and look a bit more broadly than
these anecdotal examples we wanted to
see the extent to which bacteria
interact with fungi and how these might
be controlled by us to manipulate larger
ecosystem so our focus is primarily on
soil this is a Department of Energy
Office of Science funded project and one
of the goals is to be able to use
reclaimed or poor land for biomass
production either for biofuels or for
agriculture and to do this we we and
many others are thinking about how we
can
[Music]
control the microbial to reach our end
and goals and desires so we're
interested in all manners of
interactions between fungi and bacteria
some of our group or collaborators have
been studying how bacteria traverse
these open air pockets and soils these
unsaturated soils using fungal highway
systems so using the fungal mycelium to
traverse open space we're also of course
interested in endo bacteria similar to
the first example I'd presented but
we're really interested in what is the
diversity and is there any specificity
to these bacterial fungal interactions
and what are their implications of these
particular lifestyles on their evolution
as well as how do they acquire or
transmit these bacterial partners over
time so fortuitously a current postdoc
in our group was doing this PhD not very
far away in albuquerque and part of his
study was to look at this very
interesting group of fungi called Manas
barosky's they're quite cosmopolitan
they're found in across this fairly arid
southern us soils and they're associated
with plants now normally fungi are
associated with a particular species of
plant but monster ascus is not very
picky choosing a large number of
partners with which to form associations
that was one of the first interesting
things outside of it being found in a
pretty wide geographic area another
interesting thing is how diverse it
looks phenotypically when you grow it on
on these nutrient agar plates these are
different lineages or different lines
- for a space and you can see how they
all look a little bit different to the
left I'm showing one particular strain
of Manas brassicas and how it grows in
relationship to another isolate of Manas
brassicas in many cases you might see
this inhibition zone where this one
strain is kind of inhibiting or where
they're inhibiting each other to grow
right in the middle this is not true in
the bottom-left chart of the of the left
picture the bottom left corner you can
see when it's grown with itself it grows
happily in the middle and we noticed
this also with completely different
strain also in the others you'll see
this pigment forming right at the line
of that of that zone of inhibition in
the top right corner we're looking at
these two different isolates with four
other isolates and they seem to have a
similar patterns creating this
inhibition zone and also creating this
red substance which we've zoomed into at
the bottom and this is a polyketide
which called bike of Aaron which is
likely the root cause for this this
inhibition and control of other partners
in soil we still don't know exactly what
it does but that's one of the hypotheses
so Aaron had set out to understand the
genomic diversity of this very
interesting fungal lineage and to the
left I guess showing a tree of Manas
brassicas in blue were Samba lineages
that were known already of existing
described species and in red in black
were new isolates and in red are ones
that they selected for whole genome
sequencing that the join genome
Institute also run by the Department of
Energy interestingly in three of these
lineages and one in particular
there was something unexpected found in
the genome assembly so as Aaron was
looking through the functional potential
he ran across these this very
interesting large con take that assemble
then looks a lot like a bacterium so as
it turns out three of these lineages
three of these lines seem to have pretty
strong signals for this real tonyia
organism and there's a tree to the right
you can see all three of these and
despite the fully lineages and the
diverse nature the fungal lineages
they're found in the the Ross tonyia
Paquette EIC cleanse appears to be quite
similar at least among these three
different isolates and that's a whole
genome snip tree to the right so this
was a fortuitous discovery most groups
when their sequence in fungi only care
about the fungi that they're sequencing
and will discard what they consider
contaminants we wanted to see if we
could take advantage of that and of the
many genomes that have been sequenced by
the joint genome Institute that they
have a fungal genomes project which
which has focused on getting diverse
lineages of fungi sequenced and so we
wanted to look to see whether or not
there were any particular patterns of
bacteria showing up in some of these
different fungal projects so another
postdoc Jeffery house developed this
pipeline to look at at these genome
sequencing data we also were doing at
the same time screens of cultures which
I'll get you to later
so in this pipeline is simply assembly
of the raw data after some duration and
then discarding anything that we can
essentially guarantees fungal host since
that's not what we're interested in
these projects
[Music]
and then look at all the rest of the
assembled data and try to redo a new
assembly on improved assembly of just
this focused data and and reads and
group these into bins of like context
that this is something that's
traditionally done in metagenomics to
try and pick pieces of the assembly that
belong together and try and assemble a
full genome out of them
and then we try and classify that bin of
different contexts and see what it might
be
taxonomic we selected the two of the
three fungal genome projects that Aaron
had been involved in with the strong
signals of Manas brassicas of roquette
cassia sorry bostonia the KDI and and
use this as a way to discern kind of the
low end of where our cutoff should be to
determine what and when you find a
bacterial partner present and so that is
what we used as our baseline cut-offs
and what we found out of 412 at the time
fungal genome projects was about 6
percent have a very strong bacterial
signal similar to the Gastonia signal in
brassicas and so this chart to the left
you can see the fungal genomes or some
of the fungal genomes are listed to the
left they're color-coded by their by the
fungal phylum that they belong to so
we've looked at a number of different
representatives or representative
lineages the bacteria that are found are
at the bottom which is probably
illegible on your screen as it is online
and then the darker colored the dots and
the larger the dots the morgue
there was and the more of the
completeness of the bacterial genome was
assessed and so you can see for a number
of these there's a single hit I'm taking
this particular one as an example since
Mariela along ghada's known to have an
endo bacterial partner called micro
abacus and so this was quite expected
but it also showed that this pipeline
holds promise for detecting strum
bacterial signals but we also took two
metagenomes to a bona fide metagenomes
there to liken metagenomes and in like
an eel you often have fungi associated
with either sign a bacteria or with with
algae and here we see Na stock in this
lab area or linked with this lab area
lichen as expected
now this cutoff is fairly stringent it
had a sufficient amount of data so that
your bacterial genome can actually
assemble and then it has to assemble
well enough so that it can bin be bin
together with the rest of the components
of the genome so for the most part you
have primarily very well complete
genomes 50% or more complete that we're
analyzing but what of bacterial partners
that are not in high abundance with
respect to to their fungal hosts it's
possible that were simply missing a lot
of this signal and so Jefferies also
started looking at Reed based analytics
meaning we simply look at every single
Reed from the data set and try to
understand what they might be hitting or
which taxon they might belong to which
which bacteria that maybe walked back in
this we also remove what we deemed to be
certainly the fungal genome host and
then we're looking for all of the rest
of the data and look to see bacterial
signal and you can see here we find
bacteria had much lower depths of
coverage or weed or amounts of
sequencing Kieran's measured both these
actually x axes are measured in fold
coverage of the fungal genome but that
also just represents total amount of
data and so we get much better signals
with read based analytics i thought i'd
segue just a little bit to tell you of
some of our efforts in this area but
also some of the caveats and some of the
pitfalls of doing read based analytics
so if false discovery is the largest
problem sequencing reads are fairly
short outside of the pad bowel and mana
poor lung read technologies they're
quite short even if they're high quality
so they have little information content
and trying to ascertain what an organism
is from this short stretch of
nucleotides is not always trivial nor is
processing so much data and a lot of the
tools out there have focused on the
latter we had worked for a number of
years on two of called gacho which is at
the top of this chart to try and
specifically focus on optimizing for for
specificity without losing too much
sensitivity so on the y axes for both
these charts the chart to the left is
work that we had done maybe four or five
years ago and the chart to the right is
something that's a little bit newer and
typical tests that we do with mock data
set provided by the human microbiome
project in both these charts the left
one is with a simulated community of a
hundred organisms
and on the right as I mentioned is a
mock data set of only 20 different
organisms or so I'm showing the true
counts on the left with a hundred
organisms either identified or not
correctly in blue and then false
negatives and green and false positives
in red so organisms that are called even
if it's only by a few reads to be
present in that data set on the on the
right it's just proportional base but
you can see that many tools have this
problem as well it's over identification
so what are the criteria for determining
whether or not an organism is present
and this is a an open-ended question
that no one really has a great answer to
you know we all care about what the
important organisms are and so the
question is does does it mean to be
abundant abundant to fulfill a role and
the ecosystem or to perturb the
ecosystem or - or is it just important
in the cases that you're interested in
such as a pathogen detection perhaps so
it depends on what type of sample if you
expect it to be highly abundant and also
whether or not it's a highly diverse
community that you're sequencing
innocence the majority of times you're
sequencing many other things at the same
time even if it's only one organism with
a host the host may completely overwhelm
signals from from smaller genomes or
smaller organisms so these are all
considerations and in addition how do
you find novel organism since the hits
won't be perfect and they may in fact
hit to a number of different references
the reference database itself is the
primary importance and there are issues
with the current with the status of
current databases both in terms of
nomenclature issues
contamination and miss naming issues but
also just in general bias since we have
seen there's a lot more pathogens than
environmental organisms so we've sought
out to develop a scoring system that
isn't a hundred percent tied to relative
abundance or to bones so I'm just
showing you conceptually how this newer
system might work you have the fast
queue file we have a number of different
databases and we try and keep them both
up to date and fairly complete and we
use our initial effort with our gotcha
tool to identify unique signatures and
all genomes and with that we can look at
data at any level of taxonomy and see at
what level of taxonomy is that sequence
unique uniquely found and then we can
give you rank specific mapping results
and we can add a couple of different
scores to this either looking against a
background if you are looking at
environmental perturbation or using a
score that's that's based on our
database as we currently know it despite
its flaws so any one genome will have
some portions of the genome that are
specific to the strain or to the genus
or family or the to the phylum and we
can group these as such and for every
genome in the database we already have
this calculation performed since we've
done in all by all comparisons so this
gives us kind of this posterior
probability for what we might expect if
we were to randomly sample this genome
you know what's the probability that I
would get something at the genus level
that's specific and then with that or
you know what is that what's the
probability that it is that that genus
and so coupling on to this
it's not always easy for biologists to
approach bioinformatics tools there are
a number of dependencies there are a
number of issues so we've been playing
around with in a number of different
efforts on how to make bond phonetics
methods more available and amenable to
biologists so annotating essentially a
screen shot of a webpage output from
from this tool which will provide you an
overview dashboard of what you found
[Music]
specific results as well as a number of
different metrics like how many reads
mapped every organism and then an
interactive map a dot plot showing you
the data and then more information below
which I'll go through in just a second
you can toggle any of the parameters and
then see real time differences in your
results so you can adjust these filters
or search things by taxonomy you can
switch things to the strain level so you
can look at by genome hit you can lower
all of your filters so that you can find
more organisms that might be at much
lower abundances or where there are only
a few reads them up to the genome you
can mouse over these and get more
details look at whether or not you've
got complete or incomplete genome
coverage and then add a number of
features to this everything will
eventually hit our open-source github
repo and we will also be integrating as
we do with most of our tools into our
edge bioinformatics platform which is a
separate project I don't have time to
talk about today but you can visit any
one of these sites and it should lead
you to further documentation and to
enter more information
so for fungal bacterial interactions and
bacterial signatures so we showed just
the genome screens and how we have been
successful finding actually a large
number or different bacteria in a wire
agenda there's a fungi we also have
access to a number of culture
collections from Europe from the US and
from South America as well
and we want to screen these using more
traditional 16s community profile so
this is where you're amplifying the
portion of the ribosomal RNA sequence
and we're trying to identify what taxa
are present in your sample
these are fungal collections that have
been passage tests sometimes years
others were fairly fresh and this very
complex heat map essentially shows you
in color from yellow to dark whether or
not things have been found that are
abundant on the right this time you have
the different fungi fungal lineages that
have been screened so hundreds of
strains have been screened and we have
found hundreds of different bacterial
genera so we only went down to the genus
level and you can see some of them are
found across a number of different fungi
and others are more specific to
independent families or or specific
strains of a function we want to prove
that these 16s signals are real and so
we've performed a number of different
microscopy tests this is a fish
fluorescence in situ hybridization stain
of using 16s a Universal 16s probe
against raisa plus one that we obtained
from a tsetse culture collection and
this is a pirkled area that's known to
be associated with raisa puss
let me see it quite clearly and then
we've also screened our our unique
collections of fungi and we have found
similarly that some of them the house a
mild to very high burden of what
appeared to be bacteria inside the
fungal hyphae
and I don't have confocal images to show
you otherwise I can show you that we do
believe they're actually inside one
signal that had perturbed me originally
was the last signal it's found in a
number of different fungi we thought
this was simply a matter of bound
fanatic error you know parameters you
are whether or not we had some level of
contamination to the right I'm just
showing a zoomed in just of that
chloroplast line and you can see it's
spread really throughout all the
different fungal defy line at the very
bottom are unclassified phyla I should
have mentioned so you know fungi for all
I remembered from even grade school
biology maybe not great school but high
school biology was that fungi do not
have them and a Wikipedia backed me up
of course they're not the ideal source
of their number new and older papers
their textbooks that tell you they that
none have chloroplasts or there have
been presentations where this is one of
the top things that that are presented
and even scientific fliers describing
fungal cells that essentially are
without core applause so so we were set
to prove that we that we had this signal
and it was just a contaminant of sorts
[Music]
but due to a very persuasive set of
students and and studies
we believe we've found otherwise this is
just showing you an abundance profile of
the different of different fungi on the
x-axis and the amount of chloroplast
signal found in each fungal lineage so
we find it across all three collections
it can be up to 20 percent of all 16s
data they are found across different
lineages of fungi and the next thing
tasked was sequence similarity wise were
they all the same sequence because that
would point perhaps to contamination on
visit on a plant that just shows the
distribution of taxonomies that we've
assigned these stay nest and on those a
bit more indicate phylogeny
of this short stretch about 400 or so
base pairs of the 16s sequence coupled
with a number of different sequences of
chloroplasts from many different trees
or plants from algae and and also 16s
from cyanobacteria which is at the top
in blue and you can see the dots the
different colored dots represent four
different collections that we've
screened and you can see they're spread
throughout this tree and the the lowest
large clade on the right is all land
plants above it in dark green are algae
and then above that in cyan color the
cyanobacteria so we we have done a good
job not picking cyanobacterial 16s
sequences in this analysis and really
focusing on those that we've
leave our chloroplasts like but they
they appear to hit throughout the tree
and so we followed this up also with
fish staining designing a chloroplast
specific probe that test some negative
on negative controls and this is one
picture showing how it looks with this
fungal hypha mat and a close-up view
showing you the structure that we find
it has along the hyphy along fungal
hypha this is with a environmentally
obtained isolate of mordor Ella which is
known to frequently associated with a
few different types of bacteria but not
before characterized to associate with
chloroplasts or half chloroplasts the
story is to be continued we're
investigating this on about eight
different fronts we have found
signatures and other data sets that are
not generated by us so we do believe
this might be real and fairly novel
discovery and switching topics however
we're also interested in bacteria that
are not simply inside fungal cells so
most fungal culture collections they've
been passage sometimes we're using
antibiotics to get rid of contaminating
EXO bacteria and so collaborators that
are part of our project Saskia and pilar
have been interested in developing
techniques to look at these bacteria
that are associating with the outside of
fungi and as I mentioned before bacteria
are kind of limited in where they can
move due to water biofilms and water
biofilms that form inside inside soils
soils are mostly unsaturated fungi do
quite well in unsaturated systems and
bacteria can use these fungi as highways
to traverse
open space so the pilar inner group had
developed these fungal highway columns
with filters to prevent mites or
anything else larger than fungal hypha
from traversing into the into the middle
portion which is filled with agar that
can attract soil organisms since this
exposed directly to soil and at the top
there's another plug of agar that
attracts fungal hypha to traverse this
open-air space which is filled with
beads representing soil structure and
and reached the top and then you can
look specifically at what's up top that
managed to traverse this open space we
have several models of this these are
all handmade or hand designed so they're
not entirely consistent but we have done
a number of replicates studies and have
isolated a number of different fungi and
bacteria isolates we for the fungi we've
used antibiotics to to counter select
bacteria and then look inside those
fungi for endo bacteria as well and
we're characterizing these in much the
same way that we've characterized all
the other data that i've presented thus
far we've since designed a 3d model of
this so that we can more consistently is
this send out to other groups that are
interested in soil fungi or soil
bacteria that news fungi to traverse
these air pockets and these are also
going to be used or are being used in a
number of outreach efforts teaching the
next generation of scientists more about
how important microbes are to the
well-being of everyone and the in breath
so with that we have a large team as
part of this science focus area project
on bacterial fungal interaction
that's been group in Switzerland that
Universitatea shot em as well as
University of Houston Colorado State
Vanderbilt and a number of other
upcoming collaborators and a lot of the
work that was done by the postdocs and
students as part of this group has also
been supported by a large array of
genomics and bioinformatics personnel
that are really the underpinning for all
the analytics we have a github site for
the software that I'd mentioned from
there links to websites and papers my
email was on the first slide you're
welcome to email me if you have any
questions and I thank you very much for
your attention